the jurogan experience well it's
crazy to watch the method when you see
the method of how they cut the cocaine
on your show where they're pouring
cement into it you're like what
and then gasoline just giant jug and
then like
all the other [ __ ] that they're all the
different chemicals acid they're like oh
my god this is cry i had no idea
i had no idea that's how they make it
yeah it's so so another
episode that we filmed recently was here
in austin was actually meth
math is in austin yeah on my way driving
here to the show
i passed by the place where i had filmed
just three weeks ago actually this uh
this guy in his hotel room a dealer a
meth dealer but he was washing one of
the things he did before
he started getting clients and the
clients are not the people that you
think are meth users at all
by the way we filmed we interviewed a
lawyer we interviewed a mom with kids at
home
it was an entrepreneur not at all the
people that you think are meth users
and this guy before he started he's
washing the meth
um and that's because he says he prides
himself on selling good quality meth but
he had purchased it from
mexico and he wasn't sure about the
quality so he washes it i can't remember
what it is the product that he puts in
but it's to see
all the other stuff that comes out and
uh and him you know you can
and then you can see just sort of all
this other chemicals that are put in
there
and you sort of realize and when i was
filming in the cocaine lab the same
thing
and the fentanyl lab too the amount of
[ __ ] that goes into these drugs
if that alone is not going to dissuade
you from from doing them it's
yeah it's chemicals it's gasoline
it's yeah lime lime is something that
goes into a lot of these
you know yeah they use the line to get
rid of bodies
yeah oh yeah the this um
meth guy um was he a big breaking bad
fan was a
big brian cranston fan wanted to he was
he was younger i don't i'm sure
you know one guy that we filmed for the
fentanyl episode it was a
cartel chemist so this this guy was a
bio engineer
um and incredibly smart and
knowledgeable and we met him in this
abandoned location where he's
basically making fentanyl and pressing
it into the m30 pills which are fake
um it goes round back to the beginning
of the opiate crisis because they make
them to look like oxycontin like the 30
milligram pills that purdue pharma
and so but it's pure fentanyl
essentially and and they're becoming
really popular on the streets of america
and part you know
really deadly stuff and so we saw him
making it
and you never know with these guys like
i spent time in some of these illicit
labs where
you kind of get a sense that [ __ ] could
go wrong very fast because they have no
idea what they're dealing with and these
are very potent chemicals
but in this case you know it's not easy
to make i mean it is because it's cheap
and once you know how to do it you know
how to do it but it's
you know i can't show up and try to make
that the thing the whole thing could
explode just because the
chemicals are so potent and yet here he
was and we were wearing our hazmat suits
and our masks and everything
and i started talking to him and he was
i mean
i suddenly thought i was talking to
walter white from breaking that
he was exactly that like a geek when it
came to
chemistry and had always loved chemistry
and you know had worked in chemistry for
a while and then was approached by the
sinaloa cartel and they needed a guy who
knew how to do
how to make this stuff and and he's
decided why not i can make a lot more
money making this
and now he's like one of the biggest
chemists for the scenario cartel
yeah so when you talk to the people that
did the meth do they have a reason
the people that that actually consume it
when you said you talked to
they use it yeah the mom and the lawyers
it's a good party
um drug it's a good uh it's a good it's
a
it helps with inhibition for people yeah
and apparently it really helps with uh
sex especially it's uh
very consumed in the gay community as
well
it helps yeah just um having a good time
and it's getting wild yeah getting wild
yeah yeah um
have you done adderall i have not good
for you you and i together give me some
knuckles woman
all right you have another no but that's
a tempting one people keep telling me
how amazing it is for like just cleaning
your house
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between
video and audio experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre
in the background by using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience